in the end one Bryant Park tower will
stand tall 365 meters high
when it is fully operational the tower
will be one of the greenest in the world
and it may be leading the way into our
urban future
the building is expected to reduce both
energy and water consumption by 50% and
its occupants will benefit as well they
will have a healthier environment they
will have clean air to breathe they will
be in an environment that they can feel
not only proud about but we will be
giving them a better a physical
environment to be in and this is a good
blueprint for the future but with the
high cost of building green and with
global temperatures rising can one
bryant park make an impact by itself
usually one building won't make a
difference we've got to really get this
widespread cause for manhunt on a small
island but we really have to transform a
huge numbers of surfaces and systems and
technologies in order to make a dent in
the climate
some believe the momentum has already
begun to shift and the trend may be
contagious many of the ideas in one
Bryant Park are finding their way into
other buildings already and in another
few years we'll see lots and lots of
things like it I don't think there's any
question but that we're at a tipping
point maybe we've crossed it we're
already over the line the goal was to
create the greenest building we possibly
could so people are watching carefully
like gee how did the Bank of America
decide to spend the money to do a
seriously green building and in that
small way I hope that the building will
be a trigger for lots of other projects
around the country and around the world